So data store is a great way to store
and retrieve massive amounts of data. So therefore, it is
very scalable. But it would still be faster if the
data was served from memory. As we know, we want
our application to have as small latency as possible.
So whatever we can do to reduce this, the better.
This is exactly where Memcache comes in handy. As the
name suggests, Memcache is a memory cache which sits next
to your app engine instances. Any data you store
here can be immediately retrieved without having to read from
data store. So when you store data in data store,
you can also store a copy of Memcache. That means
you can retrieve it from Memcache later, and therefore deliver
response really, really fast. This is great, since you don't
want your users to wait. Both Datastore and Memcache are
shared across any number of instances of your application that
app NU starts. This means that they can all
access the same data provided that your application updates
Memcache when it updates Datastore. The difference between Memcache
and Datastore however, is that Memcache is a cache.
This means that the app engine platform can decide
to free memory at any time, in which case
the retrieve operation will fail. So your application code
needs to be prepared if this happens, and in that
case retrieve the data from Datastore. Let's look at
a summary of Memcache. Memcache is of course, not limited
to cache Datastore information. You can put any data you
want in Memcache. Since the data is retrieved directly from
memory, the latency is very low. This help it build
applications that can scale to extreme levels. But since it's
a memory cache, it also means that the memory could
be freed and the data be evicted from the cache.
So your code can not rely on it always
residing in the memcache. All right, that's the overview
of Memcache, it's now time for you to hack
in by adding Memcache functionality to the comfort central app.